[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
Bienvenue c'est sens public votre
rendez-vous quotidien de débat et de
reportages on se retrouve tous les jours
du lundi au jeudi à 18h et 22h sur
Public Sénat pour donner du sens à
l'actualité grâce à nos invités experts
90 minutes de grands thèmes avec un
débat d'actu pour commencer consacré ce
soir au bal des pariables Vladimir
Poutine et Kim de dictateurs dans le
viseur des pays occidentaux soumis à des
sanctions sans précédent et qui n'arment
la communauté internationale avec cette
rencontre où il devrait être question
d'armes et de munitions mais que peut
fournir l'industrie militaire
nord-coréenne avec quelle contrepartie
ce partenariat n'est-il pas aussi un
constat de faiblesse pour Vladimir
Poutine réponse juste après ces titres
et puis comme nous le faisons
régulièrement depuis la création de
cette émission il y a deux ans notre
second débat sera volontairement décalé
de l'actualité du jour il portera sur
l'un des mots de cette rentrée
l'autorité déclinée sous toutes ses
formes
l'ordre l'ordre l'ordre le respect du
professeur et de son autorité ce qui est
bon c'est la fermeté
donc compatriotes attendent de la
fermeté le but c'est évidemment de punir
et moi j'assume cette fermeté
deux mois après les émeutes le retour à
l'autorité est au cœur de tous les
discours politiques pas seulement ceux
du gouvernement comment la restaurer
depuis quand est-elle en danger est-ce
forcément une valeur de droite beaucoup
de questions passionnantes à poser à nos
invités d'ici trois quarts d'heure mais
d'abord donc ce train blindé nord-coréen
qui rentre sur le territoire russe c'est
l'une des images fortes de ce mardi
symbole d'une alliance entre deux pays
au banc des nations démocratiques Flora
sauvages c'est la première visite du
dirigeant nord-coréen depuis la pandémie
de covid-19 partie dimanche aborde un
tremblindé Kim Jong-un est arrivé en
Russie pour rencontrer Vladimir Poutine
obus missile antichard après 23 mois de
guerre en Ukraine Moscou chercherait à
s'approvisionner auprès de la Corée du
Nord Pyongyang serait intéressé par la
technologie de pointe russe pour des
satellites et des sous-marins nucléaires
ce que tout le monde dit c'est que la
Corée du Nord va fournir des armes à la
à la Russie je ne suis pas sûr malgré
tout ça des objectifs premier je ne suis
pas sûr que la Corée du Nord soit en
mesure d'apporter des armes vraiment
intéressantes pour la pour la Russie
aujourd'hui ce que l'on observe avec
cette visite c'est la volonté des deux
pays de montrer que ils ne sont pas
aussi isolés qu'on le prétend pour
Washington le rapprochement de Moscou
vis-à-vis de Pyongyang représente un
aveu de faiblesse
avoir à traverser tout son pays pour
rencontrer un paria de la scène
internationale afin de lui demander de
l'aide dans une guerre qui l'espérait
gagner en un mois je dirais que ça
revient à quémander de l'aide
mais selon cette chercheuse en se
rapprochant de la Corée du Nord Vladimir
Poutine adresse un message aux
Occidentaux et à la Corée du Sud Séoul
fournit un directement des armes à
l'Ukraine via la Pologne il y a de
grandes chances pour que la volonté de
la Russie soit d'exercer des pressions
sur la Corée du Sud en se rapprochant
comme ça de manière très officielle de
la de la Corée du Nord
la lumière Poutine est actuellement à
Vladivostok pour un forum économique
selon le Kremlin il devrait rencontrer
Kim Jong-un dans les jours à venir rien
à filtrer ni sur la date ni sur le lieu
de la rencontre
le bal des paria c'est le thème de notre
débat joue présente nos invités Patricia
Lemonnier bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes
grand reporter spécialiste des relations
internationales et vous publiez ce livre
au cœur du chaos aux éditions
Artaud Pierre-Antoine Denève bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes journaliste à
asialis et je cite également votre livre
le dossier chinois portrait d'un pays au
bord de la Bible publié aux édition du
Cherche-Midi chigna aussi que vous étiez
rédacteur en chef chez nos confrères de
l'Agence France Presse Florent
Parmentier bonsoir et bienvenue à vous
vous êtes secrétaire général du CI pop
Sciences Po chercheur associé au Centre
de géopolitique de HEC et j'accueille et
mini zapalski bonsoir Émilie spécialiste
de communication politique éditorialiste
pour sens public bienvenue à vous aussi
je vais commencer par ce qui est
peut-être anec pas tant que ça remarquer
ce c'est étonnant voyage en train vous
allez voir sur sur une carte la
frontière nord-corraine n'est pas très
éloignée de Vladivostok 130 km alors on
est très loin du TGV sur les moyennes
horaires 60 km/h maximum ton estimé 20h
pour ce voyage Patricia lemonnière je
pose une question pourquoi va-t-il aussi
lentement ce train qu'est-ce qu'on est
qu'est-ce qu'on en sait de ce train
alors il va lentement parce qu'il est
blindé en haut sur les côtés bon ça
c'est ça c'est l'histoire du blinda ce
train il existe depuis pratiquement
toujours sous des formes différentes le
grand-père de l'actuel dirigeant
nord-coréen utilisait déjà un train il
en avait pris un pour se rendre à Moscou
alors imaginaire 60 km/h combien de
temps il avait mis pour se rendre à
Moscou le dirigeant nord-coré qui me le
prend l'avait pris pour aller au Vietnam
pour rencontrer Trump bon quand il
l'avait rencontré à Singapour il avait
pas pris le train et pris l'avion
exceptionnellement mais ce train lui
seul il raconte ce qu'est le régime il
raconte sa paranoïa la peur d'être
attaqué il raconte le fait que ce régime
s'appuie sur la force et donc le
militaire le nucléaire il raconte aussi
son son outrecuidance vis-à-vis de son
peuple qui crève de faim parce que dans
ce train imaginez-vous il y a le
satellites il y a des antennes de
télévision il y a des écrans de
télévision et vous pouvez manger tout ce
que vous voulez du caviar de homard du
vin français dit ce qu'ils l'ont
emprunté et enfin ce train il raconte
aussi et bien j'ai envie la volonté de
deux régimes paria comme vous l'avez dit
de se renforcer renforcer l'alliance
face au bloc
occidentaler cet aspect mais
Pierre-Antoine Denay vous êtes allé en
Corée du Nord on y reviendra et ce train
Patricia et un peu évoqué il pourrait
être le symbole effectivement de du
mépris de des Kim pour pour un peuple
qui est quand même affamé avec le luxe
l'opulence mais c'est il est il est
affiché il est on peut le visiter il est
il est devenu un symbole de du pouvoir
et du pays je précise que le grand-père
qui met le son avait une phobie des
avions il n'en prenait jamais et d'un
point de départ de l'histoire exactement
mais Kim jongle a pris l'avion donc
c'est différent alors ceci vous savez le
régime non coréen quand on voit dans ce
pays mais c'est non seulement effrayant
mais c'était épouvantable c'est un
système politique qui dépasse
l'entendement et le raisonnement humain
je ne vois pas d'autres pays avec lequel
le comparer il y a effectivement comme
vous l'avez dit comme vous l'avez dit
une population qui est affamée il y a de
façon récurrente des famines
épouvantables ou la population meurt par
dizaines de milliers et centaines de
milliers et il y a ce régime unique qui
effectivement là
possède tous les attributs d'une nomade
tatoura extrêmement riche qui profite de
tout c'est un émissaire russe je crois
qu'il y avait raconté effectivement
l'opulence à l'intérieur de de ce train
on va rentrer un peu plus dans les dans
les enjeux diplomatiques toujours à
propos de Kim pour pour commencer on
fera un focus côté rue c'est un peu plus
tard Florent Parmentier pour lui pour le
dictateur nord-coréen c'est quoi l'enjeu
de cette de cette rencontre d'après vous
trois enjeux je pense qui se qui se
dégagent et on pourrait revenir
d'ailleurs un peu plus en détail un
enjeu militaire montrait que et bien la
Corée du Sud peut fournir non pas des
armes de précision c'est pas du Nord
mais pas au même pas même quand la Corée
du Nord fournit n'ont pas les armes de
précision mais plutôt des armes massives
or ce qu'on a observé sur le terrain de
la guerre en Ukraine c'est l'utilisation
massive de l'artillerie par conséquent
la question n'est pas celle du
perfectionnement de ces armements mais
plutôt de la quantité disponible et
là-dessus on peut penser effectivement
que les choix qui n'ont pas été faits en
faire de la population l'ont été en
faveur d'un stock d'armement qui depuis
1953 a dû et bien proliférer et
certainement je pense que ça c'est le
premier enjeu le second enjeu à mon sens
pour qu'il
est un enjeu diplomatique si deux
parieurs se rencontrent c'est une chose
si plusieurs s'il y a une Internationale
des parias alors vous êtes dans une
réalité parallèle c'est-à-dire vous êtes
dans une autre forme de communauté
internationale celle des parieurs mais
vous n'êtes plus le vilain petit canard
au sein d'un système guerre mondiale qui
serait totalement unifié or
ce qu'on a observé depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine et une forme de
fragmentation du monde qui s'est
accélérée fragmentation qu'on a pu voir
évidemment sur la question des sanctions
par exemple ou la position
occidentale n'est pas partagée très
largement au-delà de au-delà de ses
frontières troisième enjeu des enjeux
certainement économiques on a la fois
une capacité de production en Corée du
Nord mais il y a aussi très certainement
des formes de complémentarité qui sont
assez facilement faciles à imaginer
entre d'un côté une population qui
effectivement a des problèmes
d'approvisionnement de nourriture moins
qu'à certaines périodes récentes de
l'histoire mais il y a à côté surtout un
grenier à blé qui a massivement la
possibilité d'exporter son bien son blé
comme une capacité politique il va y
avoir un donnant donnant on y reviendra
là aussi merci d'avoir posé les les
enjeux principaux peut-être pour rester
sur
l'utilisation que Kim Jong-un va pouvoir
faire de ces de ces images pour
l'instant il y en a très peu il y a
l'image du train il y aura sans doute on
sait pas quand on sait pas où dans
quelques jours la rencontre et elle sera
peut imaginée immortalisée et donc il y
aura ces images comment il les utilise à
quel point le peuple nord-coréen et
j'allais dire lobotomiser le terme est
un peu fort mais comment elles sont
utilisées ces non le terme est pas trop
fort il est même carrément de dessert
est vrai vous savez en fait encore une
énorme le seul moyen d'information c'est
la formation officielle donc la
désinformation alors il y a longueur de
journaux les portraits de Kim Jong-un
qui fait
quand ils seront sur place pour donner
des conseils à un hôpital ou voilà il
n'y a que ça donc là évidemment ce
voyage servira à renforcer encore son
image en est-il vraiment besoin je ne
sais pas à vrai dire je pense qu'il a
tout à y gagner sur le plan
international parce qu'effectivement il
sort de chez lui c'est la première fois
ça a été dit depuis le début de la
pandémie et il est reçu bon par voilà on
sait effectivement que là aussi c'est un
coca c'est l'alliance des coquins
moi je trouve que celui qui vraiment
montre à vrai dire à quel point il
semble aux abois c'est la lumière
Poutine
on en parlera plus longuement oui il a
beaucoup plus à perdre et effectivement
on peut y voir un concept faiblesse mais
ça ce sera le thème de votre chronique
on y viendra un petit peu plus tard
parce que je voudrais quand même qu'on
se concentre un peu sur sur la question
des armes vous l'avez un peu évoqué on
va essayer d'être prudent parce que moi
ce que j'entends depuis deux jours
depuis qu'on a eu l'annonce de cette
visite c'est voilà il va y avoir un
accord sur des armes etc etc ecoutons ce
qu'on dit le porte-parole du Département
américain c'est évidemment l'équivalent
de notre ministère des Affaires
étrangères mise en garde des Américains
écoutés
de cette rencontre je rappellerai aux
deux pays que tout transfert d'armes de
la Corée du Nord vers la Russie
constituerait une violation des
multiples résolutions du Conseil de
sécurité des Nations unies
nous avons bien entendu imposer des
sanctions contre des entités qui
financent l'effort de Garrus nous
continuerons à les appliquer et nous
n'hésiterons pas à les renforcer et à
imposer de nouvelles fonctions
alors vous vouliez prendre la parole sur
le sur les arbres parce que dans notre
sujet d'ouverture de Flora sauvage il y
avait pas mal de conditionnel là-dessus
globalement la Corée du Nord est sur
armé il faut le savoir vraiment alors
certes ce qui intéresse Poutine c'est
notamment toutes les munitions
les missiles antichard oui mais il n'y a
pas que ça
il faut savoir que il y a des centaines
de missiles qui sont pointés sur Séoul
et qui sont prêts à être tirés à chaque
seconde ce sont des missiles à profusion
à poudre c'est-à-dire qu'il nécessite
pas d'être chargé
[Musique]
un représentant chinois important du
Parti communiste dont je ne me souviens
plus le nom vous m'excuserez et c'est
trois hommes là
de vous observer le défilé et là on
avait l'alliance effectivement qui était
en train d'apparaître comme ça et de
s'affirmer mais j'ai envie de dire que
c'est alliance
l'équipe enfin la famille sous le
grand-père en avait su en jouer
merveilleusement le grand-père jouait de
la Russie contre la Chine et bien faire
ce petit équilibre peut-être que une
nouvelle alliance entre le entre la
Russie et la Corée du Nord que les
choses soient claires
c'est la Russie qui a fait la Corée du
Nord au départ c'est le régime
soviétique qui l'a fait mais une fois
fait le grand-père s'est amusé à jouer
les deux puisque en plus il y avait une
des amours à un moment donné entre les
deux là Kim qui dépend totalement de la
Chine pour son approvisionnement ils
sont comme un extérieur 90%. finalement
et pas mécontent on parlera de l'aspect
international mais elle n'est pas
mécontent de renouer et Vladimir Poutine
venir manger dans sa main parce que
comme
c'est hyper peu avec les deux et de
venir un peu le faiseur de roi alors
vous nous y sommes ici la poudre elles
sont parce que moi quand je pense à la
j'ai certainement une vision peut-être
biaisée un peu caricatural de la Corée
du Nord mais j'imagine pas une industrie
militaire
aussi précise puissante quel est
qu'est-ce qu'on peut dire dans la
distributeur nord-coréenne aujourd'hui
même si il y a certainement plus
d'argent qui est mis là que dans les
programmes pour nourrir la population
alors si on regarde son état spécialiste
de l'armement nord-coréens ce qu'on peut
dire ce qui est apparition c'est que
régulièrement la Corée du Nord fait
montre de d'avancer technologique on
peut penser notamment dans le domaine
des missiles dans le domaine des
questions de la non prolifération reste
à savoir si la réussite à ce moment-là
bien changerait un peu son approche qui
a été plutôt l'idée de dénuclariser la
péninsule coréenne aussi elle souhaite
au contraire renforcer ce clivage là
parce que ça aura des incidences
naturellement ensuite sur la position et
les relations entre la Corée du Sud et
les États-Unis il y a également eu
récemment une communication autour du
lancement d'un sous-marin qu'il a aussi
été plus perfectionné que ce qui était
jusqu'à présent mais je pense que dans
le conflit
ukrainien et dans ce que la Russie peut
attendre de la Corée du Nord à cet
instant précis de la guerre ce qui
semble plutôt évident c'est que c'est le
stock de munitions qui est important
pourquoi parce qu'en réalité depuis 18
mois
l'Ukraine a pu tenir avec le soutien et
la livraison d'armement de l'ensemble
des pays de l'OTAN la Russie a fait
appel à un seul pays jusqu'à présent à
part ses propres réserves à l'Iran dont
elle a pris les drones là c'est
l'occasion d'avoir un second fournisseur
si on prend dans le cas présent des
munitions et bien d'artillerie quel
serait l'objectif et à quelle fin en
quelque sorte je pense que on assistera
encore pour un ou deux mois à la suite
de la contre-offensive ukrainienne telle
que se déroule aujourd'hui très
vraisemblablement
les chances de récupérer l'ensemble du
terrain sont aujourd'hui faibles je
pense qu'il faut être lucide sur un
constat qui est difficile cela nous
amènerait début 2024 très
vraisemblablement à une perspective qui
est celle d'une nouvelle offensive russe
pour lequel elle aurait besoin à peu
près du même volume de munitions et si
on regarde le conflit pour un obus tirer
par l'Ukraine vous en avez plusieurs
trois cinq dix par endroits tirés par la
Russie donc pour garder cette
supériorité de l'artillerie à un moment
où les approvisionnements européens
baisseront et les approvisionnements
américains baisseront aussi probablement
dans une perspective d'une campagne
électorale américaine alors vous avez
intérêt à faire le plein de bibelots de
bibelots qui sont pas très jolies et pas
très efficace nécessairement mais qui
seront très probablement efficaces sur
le champ de bataille dans le plan russe
dans chapitre sur les armes on va se
concentrer maintenant sur la question
des armes nucléaires et je propose à
Alexandre Poussard de nous rejoindre sur
ce plateau bonsoir Alexandre bienvenue à
vous
Russie Corée du Nord deux pays qui
possèdent l'arme nucléaire
il n'y a rien d'inhabituel
les États-Unis agissent de la sorte
depuis des décennies il place depuis
longtemps leurs armes nucléaires
tactiques sur le territoire de leurs
alliés les pays de l'OTAN en Europe
alors aujourd'hui la Russie ne montre
pas une stratégie de développement de
son arsenal nucléaire mais depuis le
début de l'invasion de l'Ukraine et bien
Vladimir Poutine ne cesse de menacer
d'utiliser cet arme nucléaire et donc
côté Corée du Nord il y a cette volonté
de s'afficher comme une puissance
nucléaire oui cela a fait 20 ans Thomas
que la Corée du Nord et sortie du traité
international de non prolifération
nucléaires qui est signée par 191 pays
et cela fait des années que le régime
communiste tente de se doter d'un
arsenal nucléaire opérationnel alors en
2018 il y a eu une poignée de main et un
accord historique entre Donald Trump et
Kim Jong-un pour stopper le programme
nucléaire nord-coréen c'était au sommet
de Singapour
mais cet accord est bien il n'a jamais
été vraiment mis en oeuvre et depuis le
débat depuis le départ de la Maison
Blanche de Donald Trump et bien la Corée
du Nord a repris son programme nucléaire
par exemple en 2017 la Corée du Nord
détenait à 55 à tête nucléaires en 2022
elle en détenait 95 et elle avait
réalisé 75 tiers d'essai domicile à
courtes et moyennes portées et en 2022
et bien Kim Jong-un n'hésitez pas à
menacer directement les États-Unis on
l'écoute
le bouton nucléaire est toujours sur mon
bureau les États-Unis doivent prendre
conscience que ce n'est pas du chantage
mais la réalité
et voilà face à cette menace croissante
nord-coréenne sur le plan nucléaire et
bien cet été un sous-marin nucléaire
américain lanceur d'engin c'est poster
dans un port de Corée du Sud ce qui a
fait encore monté un petit peu plus
l'attention merci beaucoup Alexandre
Patricia Lemonnier je me tourne vers
vous ce cet arsenal nucléaire c'est
est-ce qu'on peut dire que c'est aussi
une sorte d'assurance vie pour qui on le
compare à d'autres dictateurs notamment
tous ceux qui sont tombés depuis une
douzaine d'années en remontant au
printemps arabe est-ce que ça le protège
au sein de la communauté internationale
définitivement
le rendent il possède il possède cette
arme les essais sur la bomba sont
récents ce qui me ce qui est fascinant
enfin l'acquisition de la bomba c'est
facile ancienne que ça ce qui est
fascinant c'est la façon à laquelle il y
a une progression c'est la progression
dans dans la maîtrise de l'arsenal
nucléaire s'est fait très rapidement
quand même je veux dire souvenez-vous
quand il est arrivé je crois qu'ils en
était à trois essais pratiquement donc
vous voyez depuis 93 ils ont
complètement multiplié des multipliés
leur leur capacités nucléaire ce dont il
manque aujourd'hui et ça c'est peut-être
à cause des sanctions il manque en fait
de d'éléments d'intrant enfin de comme
dirait les spécialistes pour
miniaturiser leur tête nucléaire qui
mettent sur leur missile balistique on
portait et ça ils en ont besoin mais
est-ce que ça peut faire
les Russes pourraient leur fournir donc
c'est un peu un deal winwin en fait
comme disent nos amis chinois si vous me
permettez et je pense je partage
complètement votre avis dans ce deal le
grand gagnant pourrait bien être Kim
humaine et papoutine c'est cohérent
cette cette hypothèse parce que là on
fait on est on est on ne peut que faire
des hypothèses évidemment et puis
d'ailleurs on le saura sans doute pas
non plus officiellement à la sortie de
de cette rencontre entre et Vladimir
Poutine donc un est-ce que vous vous y
croyez à cette hypothèse d'un
donnant-donnant qui inclut une part de
technologie nucléaire si je simplifie et
deux la partie suivante de la question
c'est la réaction américaine évidemment
vous savez déjà comment la Corée du Nord
a mis au point l'arme nucléaire il n'y a
que deux pays qui ont pu lui fournir la
technologie c'est la Chine et la Russie
personne d'autre
derrière il y a l'Iran mais c'est pas le
sujet d'aujourd'hui on assiste
aujourd'hui mais ça c'est très clair et
ça s'est accéléré ces deux dernières
années à une course aux armements sur le
théâtre de l'Extrême-Orient en face de
la Corée du Nord il y a bien sûr la
Corée du Sud le Japon est derrière les
États-Unis
or il se trouve que cette alliance des
facto entre la Corée du Sud le Japon et
les États-Unis ne cesse de se renforcer
du fait de la menace nord-coréenne mais
aussi surtout de la Chine et ce qui fait
que la Corée du Nord se sentait un petit
peu à l'étroit
relativement vulnérable avec un
président de Corée du Sud qui est
beaucoup plus intransigeant que son
prédécesseur à l'égard de la Corée du
Nord donc la voie diplomatique entre les
deux elle est fermée pour un certain
temps combien de temps nul elle sait en
tout cas Nina ni l'autre ne veut
vraiment
négocier aujourd'hui le principe de la
dissiasion nucléaire on va le rappeler
c'est que on est supposé jamais utilisé
ces arbres plus jamais utilisé ces armes
est-ce que ça vaut ma question elle est
volontairement un peu naïve est-ce que
ça vaut pour un personnage comme Kim you
je pense qu'au-delà du personnage où
est-ce qu'on est face à un régime
complètement fou
effrayant et est-ce que ça vaut aussi
pour son dirigeant vous voyez ce que je
veux dire la maîtriser la difficulté
c'est que la dissuasion fonctionne si on
a affaire des acteurs purement
rationnels or ça élimine effectivement
les personnalités fantasmes ou encore on
peut imaginer qu'au sein du régime et au
sein de la de l'armée nord-coré quelques
personnes quand même qui se
permettraient de prendre le point mais
ça m'est totalement de côté un autre
aspect fondamental nucléaire qui en
réalité le risque d'accident comme ça
avait été existé au début des années 80
on se souvient qu'un un soldat un
officier soviétique avait volontairement
désobéi en précisant pas qu'il y avait
des éléments sur la carte qui bougeaient
qui étaient inquiétant et ce monsieur
Petroff a probablement évité en misant
quand même sur l'idée qu'il y avait
quelque chose qui n'allait pas à éviter
qui est quatre ou cinq missiles qui
soient envoyés de manière un peu
défensive par Union soviétique alors
même qu'elle n'avait pas été attaqué le
risque d'incident est quelque chose
d'important c'est pourquoi aujourd'hui
les spécialistes je pensais à quelqu'un
parle davantage de vulnérabilité
nucléaires c'est à dire des risques qui
existent en fait au-delà de points et on
a vu dans le cas ukrainien un élément
important aussi qui est que la
vulnérabilité nucléaire permet non
seulement de d'illustrer un peu et de
permettre de ne pas concentrer tout sur
la figure de dirigeant quand il s'agit
de dissuasion mais permet également de
prendre en compte des risques comme
celui par exemple de la centrale de la
centrale des aporigia dont on a beaucoup
parlé en août 2022 et qui est toujours
l'objet d'un certain nombre
d'inquiétudes de la part des
observateurs tout simplement parce que
l'idée qui pourrait y avoir à ce niveau
là une forme d'incident qui serait
évidemment dramatique je reviens oui
pardon
quand même l'opération de communication
elle est déjà quasiment réussi alors que
la rencontre n'a pas eu lieu on sait
même pas si elle aura lieu
officiellement c'est quand même assez
incroyable ces personnages et vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure en démarrant
sur le train blindé une espèce de mise
en scène et il y a une espèce de
similitude dans ces personnages qui
s'affichent avec un look un style très
très particulier que ça du côté de la
Corée du nord de la Russie moi je pense
à Trump aussi un des imaginaire des
styles très particuliers et puis cette
espèce de mise en scène avec ce train
qui fait que même avant qu'il arrive on
le on l'imagine la sur la carte on
l'imaginait avec ces questions posées
dès maintenant nucléaires est-ce que il
était effrayant ou pas est-ce que il est
tellement fou qu'il peut appuyer en fait
ce que je veux dire c'est que vous êtes
en train de dire qu'on tombe nous
occidentaux mais c'est normal
parce que c'est la guerre quand même et
c'est des c'est des probable alliés donc
c'est normal qu'on s'inquiète mais il y
a une opération de communication entre
les deux qui est assez forte puis
Antoine donnait est-ce que ça peut
déboucher sur rien une rencontre que de
la communication une rencontre comme
celle-là moi je passe je pense
sincèrement que non il y aura
certainement des accords qu'on ne
connaîtra pas et qui prendront peut-être
du temps à se mettre en oeuvre mais ça
n'est pas qu'une opération de comme le
grand point d'interrogation
si vous regardez la position chinoise
depuis maintenant le début de la guerre
en Ukraine quand il y a eu ces menaces
nucléaires proférées par Vladimir
Poutine à chaque fois la Chine a dit non
et elle l'a fait savoir elle l'a pas dit
publiquement parce qu'elle ne veut pas
c'est une question d'image pour pour
Poutine mais ça c'est sûr elle a trouvé
les voies de communication pour le faire
savoir elle refuse ce chantage nucléaire
si elle change de position personne ne
peut l'exclure du fait de grandes
difficultés en ce moment en Chine là
tout le jeu change là vraiment on
rentrerait dans une zone de danger on en
est pas là je pense que si vous voulez
autant on peut penser que Poutine est
entré dans un aventurisme dangereux
autant on connaît le personnage de Kim
Jong-un qui faut le moins et fantasque
autant jusqu'à aujourd'hui Sidi King
c'est montrer quelqu'un de rationnel
alors on va voir les mois qui vont venir
seront même peut-être les semaines
seront déterminantes parce
qu'aujourd'hui la situation intérieure
en Chine surtout sur le plan économique
est extrêmement grave pour lui
intervenir rebondir par une toute petite
remarque ce que vous venez de dire c'est
très intéressant justement c'est
qu'aujourd'hui Pékin à part une brève
déclaration disons nous allons continuer
à coopérer massivement etc pour rappeler
quand même qu'ils étaient là Pékin
observent Pékin à part cette déclaration
ce test c'est vraiment on les sent
hésitant sur justement la stratégie à
adapter allez-y on reprendra un peu plus
de temps pour reparler de la Chine le
régime communiste chinois a tout intérêt
à ne rien dire pour le moment parce que
c'est tout bénéfice de toute manière
si je crois qu'ils sont embarrassés
aussi alors ils vont peut-être montrer
embarrassé mais sur le fond
cette alliance des facto là qui se
dessine sur le plan militaire entre la
Russie et la Corée du Nord les arranges
parce que ça leur donne une carte à
jouer supplémentaire et en fait dans le
rapport politique de la Chine avec
l'étranger c'est toujours la même chose
c'est le levier il est plus ou moins
fort et la Chine ne comprend que le
langage de la force justement Florent
Parmentier c'est peut-être ça permet
aussi à la Chine de ne pas aller plus
loin dans son soutien à la Russie c'est
ce que j'entends en creux c'est une
ligne rouge la livraison d'armes que il
se refuse à que le pays se refuse à
franchir pour l'instant effectivement et
si on regarde un peu le le rapport le
rapport régional on pourrait se dire que
derrière il y a plusieurs choses mais on
pourrait dire que la dirigeants russes
et c'est peut-être de faire en réalité
de la Corée du Nord une forme de à la
fois de champ de livraison des stocks
d'armement ça c'est un premier point on
peut analyser les choses en stock mais
il faut aussi les analyser en flux et de
savoir si ça peut être une base arrière
productive qui permettrait d'aller PA en
fait les usines qui tournent déjà à
plein régimes et puis très longtemps
dans l'oral et bien là c'est l'occasion
de pouvoir de pouvoir les faire tourner
à plein régime avec un pays qui est
assez immualité aux tentative de
sanctions américaines a-t-on une grande
entreprise nord-coréenne qui pourrait
dire au régime vous allez m'empêcher de
d'exporter sur le marché etc non a-t-on
la nécessité au Corée du Nord de d'avoir
des dollars pour faire du commerce
international non aujourd'hui on voit
plutôt dans les flux internationaux à
une tendance qui est celle des deux
réalisations des échanges en passant par
des lois dans passant par des roupies
pour le pour l'un dans passant par
différents types de monnaies donc ce
qu'on voit en réalité est plutôt
convergent avec l'idée que
pour la Russie finalement ça permet
d'avoir un pays dans la poche qui n'est
pas exactement proche et il faut se
souvenir par ailleurs ça c'est un autre
élément qu'on n'a pas évoqué qu'au tout
début de la guerre c'est-à-dire six mois
après le début de la guerre il y avait
naturellement la question des drones
Iraniens qui étaient tombées mais on
s'était également posé la question déjà
de savoir si la Corée du Nord était
prête à fournir des armements elle a
probablement retardé l'échéance et
aujourd'hui peut-être qu'elle peut aller
d'avoir elle est capable d'avoir
davantage de leviers
la première leçon moi que je j'entends
et que je tire de vos interventions
c'est que on va parler de la Russie
juste après ça profite plutôt à la Corée
du Nord et à kimoine pourtant vous nous
dites qu'ils ont peut-être
retardé le moment où ils allaient
accepter de livrer des armes à la Russie
probablement
s'ils ont reculé c'est très simplement
parce que aujourd'hui si on se place
dans l'idée que la Russie est capable de
défendre défendre
c'est cette territoire occupé du crâne
de manière relativement efficace depuis
le début de l'offensive de du mois de
juin
donc on peut imaginer que c'est pas pour
ça que les Russes d'accord
nouvelle offensive russe probable
offensive russe en 2024
puisque un homme d'affaires était
livraison de la Corée du Nord où il y
avait Agnès soyons précis
durant l'année la première année de la
guerre et un homme un homme d'affaire
slovaque était impliqué dans les dans la
transaction alors sur les enjeux côté
russe maintenant je vous propose d'abord
une une réaction citation de la
porte-parole du ministère français des
Affaires étrangères Anne-Claire le
gendre qui nous dit ceci la Russie est
isolé au point d'être contrainte de se
tourner vers la Corée du Nord c'est une
marque très forte de son isolement
international effectivement Émilie on
peut abonder dans cette dans cette
partie de l'analyse des éventuelles
d'îles dont vous avez parlé des armes
supplémentaires pour la Russie peut-être
des technologies de pointe pour la Corée
du Nord peut-être aussi une pression sur
la Corée du Sud et bien se rapprochement
c'est un nouveau signe clair de
l'isolement chaque jour plus grand de
Vladimir Poutine si on revient un peu en
arrière avant c'était la Russie qui
était à la tête une opération militaire
spéciale en février 2022 qui était censé
délivrer l'Ukraine deonéo nazis et
qu'est-ce que devient la Russie et bien
elle est bannie un pays qui est banni
par une bonne partie des pays du monde
et les seuls alliés qu'elle trouve ne
sont autre que des régimes autoritaires
anti-démocratiques Syrie Iran Érythrée
Biélorussie et donc éventuellement Corée
du Nord tous ont un point commun ils ne
se range pas du côté de la Russie parce
qu'ils jugent forcément conflit très
juste non non c'est parce qu'ils y
trouve chacun un intérêt particulier que
ça soit stratégique commerciale
politique ou autre bon bien sûr il y a
des cas particuliers et on en a parlé à
l'instant l'Inde la Chine qui joue un
petit peu un rôle d'équilibriste dans ce
conflit et puis surtout dans leur
positionnement vis-à-vis de la Russie
mais globalement et même si Poutine
essaie de garder la face il ne peut plus
que piocher dans ses États pour espérer
avoir un peu de soutien politique
militaire ou économique et ses
opérations de communication elles font
pas long feu en ce moment et je voulais
vous parler de la dernière en date qui à
mon avis sera pas réussi plus que les
autres mais qui est quand même assez
rigolote puisqu'il veut organiser les
Jeux Olympiques des bricks donc vous
savez ce club des cinq pays Brésil
Russie Inde Chine et Afrique du Sud et
le tout comme par hasard en juin 2024
soit quelques semaines juste avant les
JO de Paris mais alors il y a quand même
des on va dire des alliances de pays non
démocratiques qui se renforcent oui
justement ça c'est un risque qui est
signaler dans un ouvrage qui s'appelle
Le Pacte des autocrates vous avez parlé
de paria c'est un ouvrage d'Isabelle
mandreau et Julien interrompt le livre
dévoile ce pacte qui n'est pas écrit
c'est pas textuel mais qui résonne je
les cite clairement sur la scène
internationale et particulièrement
depuis l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la
Russie les deux auteurs notent deux
choses importantes d'abord ces pays sont
parfois rivaux mais finalement leur
haine de l'Occident les rapproches quand
même et puis la deuxième chose c'est que
leur régime finalement prend aussi de
l'importance dans le monde ils estiment
en 2021 que 70% de la population
mondiale est gouvernée par des pouvoirs
autocratiques donc ça fait quand même
une bonne partie de la population
mondiale qu'est-ce qu'il faut en
conclure mais alors tout dépend si on
veut voir le verre à moitié vide ou le
verre à moitié plein à moitié plein on
dirait d'un côté un Poutine qui est
quand même isolé affaibli et de l'autre
des pays antidémocratiques qui avaient
ce conflit trouve un intérêt à s'allier
pour peut-être imposer un nouvel ordre
mondial alors
[Musique]
est-ce que on a un prisme un peu
déformant vu de vues d'ici des pays
occidentaux de d'Europe ou des
États-Unis sur l'isolement de la Russie
ce qui est vrai c'est de manière Poutine
et isolé en Amérique du Nord et en
Europe si on regarde ensuite la
résolution du G20 le G20 l'année
dernière avait mentionné la guerre
d'agression d'agression russe de
l'Ukraine dernièrement mois d'août elle
n'a pas
été pas exactement les talents on a
parlé de guerre en Ukraine c'est pas du
tout la même manière de présenter la
chose et ça va malheureusement moins
dans le sens d'un isolement de la Russie
sur ce plan qui a une forme non pas de
soutien il n'y a pas de soutien à elle
par rapport à ça mais une forme
d'indifférence qui convient enfin qui
qui revient à dire en fait que pour
beaucoup d'acteurs internationaux dans
un univers encore une fois beaucoup plus
fragmenté qu'auparavant l'idée est
plutôt de dire et bien oui voilà enfin
le l'Ukraine est une chose mais c'est
pas le seul conflit international c'est
pas le principal non plus quand vous
êtes soit Jakarta soit soigner des lits
soit soit à Pékin et donc il y a une
forme de relativisation de ce conflit
très important pour les Européens et
peut-être que
l'illustration de ça c'est de ministre
des Affaires étrangères indiens utiliser
en substance et bien pendant longtemps
les Européens ont
européens conseillé avec l'Europe enfin
devait être le problème du mois le
problème européen et les problèmes du
monde et maintenant il faut qu'il
comprenne aussi que les problèmes du
monde doivent être les problèmes des
Européens et de ce point de vue là on a
des formes de récrimination donc on voit
que il y a effectivement des il y a une
tendance il y a eu un très fort
isolement au début du conflit de la
Russie aujourd'hui les choses se se
polarisent pas autour de ça mais plutôt
autour des possibilités pour un ensemble
d'acteurs internationaux de pouvoir se
positionner dans un jeu ou le fait
d'avoir des divergences très fortes bien
permet de trouver des places différentes
on a le cas de maudit on a le cas
d'erdoine donc on voit des leaders forts
dans des pays qui ont une tradition
démocratique et bien se positionner
aussi de manière ambiguë si on veut
alors on a beaucoup parlé de la Chine
dans ce dans ce débat est-ce que on voit
apparaître là une sorte de triangle
Chine Russie Corée du Nord je vous
propose un extrait d'un documentaire qui
a été diffusé sur notre antenne Corée du
Nord un plan pour survivre avoir
d'ailleurs en replay sur sur notre
plateforme public chenapoint.fr écoutez
bien l'extrait qu'on a choisi c'est un
négociateur c'est un sud-coréen qui
conseille les présidents sud-coréens
depuis longues années qui a été
négociateur avec la Corée du Nord voilà
ce qui nous dit
si jamais il y a un alignement entre la
Chine la Russie et la Corée du Nord
contre les États-Unis et que cette
alliance triangulaire se solidifie voici
une zone de survie complètement nouvelle
pour Yang n'est-ce pas
pour un pays aussi petit que la Corée du
Nord ces deux grands pays la Chine et la
Russie leur fournirait ainsi une marge
de manœuvre pour survivre
comment la restriction du Conseil de
sécurité ainsi que les sanctions
américaines n'auront plus aucun effet
résultat la Corée du Nord pourra
s'installer confortablement comme à un
pays nucléaire sur la scène
internationale
Pierre-Antoine Donnay est-ce que ça veut
dire que cette rencontre à venir entre
guillemets et Vladimir Poutine se fait
forcément avec l'aval de la Chine ou pas
je ne dirais pas forcément qu'elle a
donné son aval elle a certainement été
peut-être consultée mais vous savez ces
régimes sont tellement ou pas qu'on peut
difficilement se prononcer quand juste
un rappel quand Vladimir Poutine est
allé à Pékin le 4 février l'année
dernière ou lui et siding se sont
déclarés les meilleurs amis du monde ils
disent depuis des années mais des liens
défectibles entre la Russie et la Chine
ça va pas tout à fait le même sens avant
ou après
de l'agression russe en Ukraine on ne le
sait pas les petits éléments qu'on peut
recueillir c'est de penser que non alors
maintenant aujourd'hui c'est une
situation totalement différente mais là
vous avez juste derrière vous le l'un
des portraits de Kimi moon on a dit
pendant ce débat qu'il était que son
pays était ultra dépendant
économiquement de la Chine peut-il aller
en Russie négocier et un éventuel accord
sur des armes voilà sans sans en avoir
référé à son puissant
le plus important n'est pas là
finalement vous savez
l'important c'est que la Chine trouve
avantage à ce que cette guerre continue
le plus longtemps est dur le plus
longtemps ça fait les affaires du régime
de Pékin or là si effectivement il y a
des livraisons d'armes et là je rejoins
ce que vous disiez tous les deux c'est
clair que ça va
dans le sens d'une guerre qui va durer
plus longtemps mais pourquoi la chimie a
un intérêt parce que je vais vous dire
c'est simple c'est que le dessin de la
Chine il est tout simplement diabolique
c'est de prendre le contrôle de dicter
ses lois de ce nouvel ordre mondial
qu'elle veut créer et ça elle n'en fait
pas vraiment mystère quand on étudie les
discours de 6e ping il le laisse
entendre de façon très claire les
dictateurs il faut les prendre au
sérieux quand ils parlent au nord et du
prendre sérieux avant Poutine on l'a pas
fait c'est dimpy il annonce un peu la
couleur et finalement quand la Russie
sera exemple quand son économise sera
totalement à terre et qui c'est qui va
en tirer profit c'est la Chine c'est
déjà le cas aujourd'hui alors après elle
aura toute latitude pour imposer ses
vues à la Russie à la Corée du Nord qui
est extrêmement dépendante à l'Iran qui
est un autre état voyou alors tout ça
sous un une comment dirais-je un attrait
finalement ou la Chine ne veut pas se
présenter comme un état voyou parce que
là on a deux États voyous avec les rangs
ça en fait 3 la Russie ne veut pas se
montrer comme ça donc elle attend son
heure tranquillement avec cependant une
grave hypothèque aujourd'hui qui change
un peu la perspective c'est cette crise
économique à l'intérieur de la Chine
qu'il a modifie quand même les données
alors on voit de façon très claire que
aujourd'hui en Chine la priorité n'est
plus l'économie mais l'idéologie et la
stabilité est devenu un obsédé total de
la stabilité politique parce qu'il sait
qu'à l'intérieur de son pays ça commence
à râler sec on comptera on consacrera
d'ailleurs un débat l'économie chinoise
dans quelques jours dans ce sens public
peut-être le dernier mot avec vous
Florent Parmentier on parle quand on
parle de la Chine il faut comprendre
évidemment la diplomatie chinoise en
fonction des États-Unis et de ce bras de
fer avec les Etats-Unis on l'a un tout
petit peu évoqué mais j'aurais bien
quand même terminé là-dessus la réaction
potentielle des États-Unis et vous
l'avez dit les limites de cette réaction
après je reviens à la rencontre
et Vladimir Poutine quelle est la marge
de manœuvre américaine après un
événement comme celui-là en réalité est
assez faible ce que peut faire les
États-Unis c'est renforcer ce qu'ils
font actuellement leur lien avec le
Japon et la Corée du Sud les pousser à
prendre davantage de responsabilité de
sécurité je rejoins ce qui a été dit
juste avant sur et bien la Chine et la
gagnante de la situation aussi parce que
les États-Unis sont mobilisés pour
soutenir un état en Europe pour la
première fois depuis le plan Marshall
c'est un État européen l'Ukraine qui a
eu le maxi qui a été le principal
bénéficiaire de la dame américaine c'est
quelque chose d'important or si on se
place dans une perspective ou le grand
défi des États-Unis c'est bien d'avoir
un siècle pacifique mais vers le
Pacifique de le fameux pivot dont
parlait Barack Obama alors on peut se
dire effectivement que il y a une forme
de contretemps pour les États-Unis ou ce
qui a été dit par le ministre de la
Défense américain était qui souhaitait
faire en sorte que la Russie sorte
épuisée et cassée par ce conflit on voit
que pendant ce temps la Chine n'avançait
pions quand la Russie continue la guerre
merci beaucoup merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce à ce débat qui était
passionnant j'ai rappelé les titres de
vos livres Patricia Lemonnier au coeur
du chaos publié aux éditions Artaud
d'ici quelques jours c'est ça à la fin à
la fin du mois témoignage d'une maman
reporter qui tente de maintenir le lien
avec avec son enfant alors que la guerre
des fils devant ses yeux Pierre Antoine
Denet le dossier chinois portrait d'un
pays au bord de la Bible qui est publié
aux éditions du Cherche-Midi je vous dis
à bientôt sur sur ce plateau de de
public sén